[Musique]
bonsoir lors du journal de la rédaction
de tv 60,18 bienvenue dans cette édition
voici les titres de ce mardi 28 janvier
janvier période de recensement des
données nécessaires à collecter pour
chiffrer la population française à
plaisir comme dans d'autres communes des
agents dédiés se rendent en ce moment au
domicile des habitants
élu en 2012 il sera en course pour un
troisième mandat à magny les hameaux le
maire sortant génération bertrand au
lion conduire à la candidature ensemble
pour magny les hameaux
une liste voulu sans étiquette enfin la
fête du conte continue jusqu'à dimanche
à saint quentin en yvelines une 19e
édition fait de rencontres conférences
et animations samedi dernier la
médiathèque jean rousselot à guyancourt
vous faisait voyager au travers des
traditions antillaises et puis
présentation dans ce journal de la
soirée des métiers et de l'orientation
le rendez-vous revient demain mercredi à
montigny le bretonneux à la ville de
plaisir a donc commencé son recensement
des agents se présentent actuellement
chez les habitants pour leur remettre
les consigner leurs identifiants le
reste de la démarche se passe sur
internet ou sur papier les résultats
seront rendus le 22 février à l'insee
mathilde et demi a suivi ghislaine un
agent recenseur de plaisir une fois par
an pendant un mois les agents recenseurs
de la population sonne de foyer en foyer
cela fait deux ans que gilen recense la
ville de plaisir par secteur c'est
important pour savoir si la ville de
plaisir a grandi en population qui
éventuellement servira pour gérer à
agrandir les écoles s'il faut en
supprimer en rajouter et aussi qui
servira à savoir si l'état va devoir
augmenter les subventions pour la
commune c'est parti gilen commence à
tourner elle privilégie les soirées pour
avoir plus de chance de rencontrer les
plaies du roi vous avez reçu mon
courrier
on invite passage et tout et tout est-ce
que vous manipulez facilement l'internet
où vous préféré l'option papier papier
en papier peut faire en internet
internet ça m'arrange ça vous en
revanche moi ça m'arrange
donc je je vous donne tout ce qu'il faut
sur papier ou par internet les habitants
choisissent leur mode de recensement
cantilène se présentent aux portes
elle donne toutes les informations
nécessaires pour remplir les
questionnaires
surtout on prépare nos enveloppes donc
moi j'ai rêvé cette année 185 enveloppe
donc ça nous permet aussi de repérer nos
adresses donc déjà de visu on sait déjà
où on va et quand personne ne répond
gilles m sera obligé de repasser pour
finir son recensement
je suis en train de remplir entre temps
un avis de passage que je vais laisser
dans la boîte aux lettres en mettant un
autre rendez-vous à une date précise une
heure précise
malgré les personnes qui ne répondent
pas rappelons que le recensement est
obligatoire
gilen devra rendre son classeur le 22
février à l'insee pour qu'ils étudient
les chiffres de son recensement dans
l'actualité les derniers chiffres du
chômage révélée par pôle emploi en un an
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi a
reculé de 1,3 pour cent dans les
yvelines la tendance est à -3 3% niveau
national plus forte baisse depuis la
crise de 2008
en décembre le département comptait 64
mille 100 chômeurs de catégorie a et
puisqu'on parle d'emploi sachez que le
groupe la poste annonce vouloir recruter
150 personnes cette année dans le
département une campagne d'embauché qui
sera accompagné d'une période de
formation pour les futurs facteurs si
vous êtes intéressés vous pouvez d'ores
et déjà postuler sur le site qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran un événement
pour trouver sa voie la soirée des
métiers de l'orientation on revient
demain mercredi à montigny le bretonneux
stéphanie gareau pour en parler mon
soirs où ça vous êtes en charge du pôle
jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux
qu'ils organisent
l'événement comme chaque année vous vous
êtes entouré de divers établissements
diverses structures du territoire saint
quentinois pour organiser l'événement
c'est en fait différents partenaires qui
interviennent sur le champ de
l'orientation et de la recherche autour
des métiers qui sont associés à notre
événement donc le cio d'elancourt donc
avec des psychologues de l'éducation
nationale nous avons aussi la cité des
métiers de saint quentin des partenaires
aussi sur l'alternance avec la cci par
ile de france et aussi des développeurs
de l'apprentissage
nous avons aussi venu une information
jeunesse qui collaborent souvent avec le
pôle jeunesse aussi sur cette thématique
là et des jeunes qui viennent témoigner
aussi de leur parcours
c'est beaucoup plus concret et ça
intéresse beaucoup les participants
aussi on y reviendra juste après l'heure
c'est pas l'heure de la fin janvier est
forcément pas anodine en matière
d'orientation il ya parcours supplée
veut sur parcours su peuvent se saisir
depuis la semaine dernière c'est un
moment de l'année le mois de janvier
début février où on commence à faire ses
choix d'orientation oui nous ce que l'on
propose surtout aux jeunes c'est
d'anticiper beaucoup leurs démarches
pour avoir moins de stress au moment de
formuler ses voeux vraiment prendre le
temps de faire une recherche sur les
domaines professionnels qui les
intéresseraient et pas forcément
raisonnée seulement en termes de
matières
scolaire qu'ils préfèrent donc c'est
tout un travail avec les jeunes et aussi
parfois les parents aussi pour arriver
aux échéances de façon plus posée et
réfléchie et vous parlez de stress y
notions importantes s'orienter peut
donner lieu effectivement à du stress on
fait des choix qui vont forcément influé
sur le suite de son la suite par nom de
son parcours est-ce que s'orienter
l'esprit léger
est ce que c'est possible à votre avis
si on s'y prend du coup à l'avance je
pense que c'est toujours une source de
stress parce qu'on décide sans avenir
mais c'est vrai que quand on identifie
bien les les structures ressources les
sites internet où on peut trouver des
informations fiables en étant accompagné
on peut réduire le stress est vraiment
prendre le temps de la réflexion plutôt
que de se précipiter à la dernière
minute et avoir peur de se tromper aussi
les petites choses intéressantes si on
regarde le programme de cette soirée à
des métiers de l'orientation il y aura
notamment un escape game qui sera
proposée qui permet de de parler de
l'orientation de manière ludique
justement c'est la troisième année qu'on
le propose parce que justement pour
dédramatiser un petit peu cette démarche
d'orientation
on propose ce jeu
auquel on peut participer en famille ou
avec d'autres participants et découvrir
des informations sur l'orientation de
façon très ludique et est un petit peu
au goût du jour puisque ça plaît à à
tout âge surtout aux jeunes les ça
fonctionne bien et qui pourra trouver
justement des informations ont peut être
collégiens ça peut être aussi un
étudiant il ya le campus de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines qui
est aussi tout proche
oui justement le le service
d'orientation et d'insertion
professionnelle de l'ue vs qu
participent et donnera des informations
sur les cursus universitaires mais on
peut venir sur cette soirée à partir de
la quatrième je dirais en vraiment
anticipant beaucoup là sur les choix
d'orientation mais on peut être
collégiens lycéens étudiants voire même
jeunes actifs si on envisage une
réorientation une reconversion ça
s'adresse un petit peu à tous les jeunes
jusqu'à 25 ans et quel que soit un petit
peu leur démarche
là cette soirée permet d'avoir des
informations bien complémentaire est
utile et vous disiez aussi parler par
exemple de l'apprentissage il ya un pôle
dédié qui sera proposé demain pour
l'apprentissage
il ya déjà un pôle dédié aussi en début
de soirée à 18 heures avec une
inscription sur place au préalable une
conférence qui sera animée d'une part
par le centre d'information et
d'orientation d'elancourt mais aussi par
des professionnels de l'alternance pour
montrer un petit peu le panel de
formations possibles
jusqu'au master donc des études qui
peuvent être aussi longue mais par la
voie professionnelle pour venir sur
place vous l'avez dit on peut s'inscrire
lors pour la conférence mais on peut
venir de manière totalement libre 100
places mises à part la conférence tout
est en accès libre
donc entre 17h30 et 20h30 au pôle
jeunesse et si on manque cet événement
parallèle c'est important de le préciser
le pôle jeunesse propose aussi un
accompagnement de des jeunes oui donc on
l'a on a focus sur ce thème parce que
c'est vraiment la période et pendant
encore tout le mois de février on va les
accompagner et éventuellement complété
le début d' accompagnement qu'on aura eu
demain soir avec eux mais tout au long
de l'année on peut accompagner les
jeunes dans leur projet d'orientation
les orienter vers les organismes
compétents et aussi dès la classe de 4e
3e faire des premières démarches pour
connaître les métiers voir un petit peu
les cursus on vient vous rencontrer son
rendez vous et vos trois parties des
sources à montigny-le-bretonneux tout à
fait ça rendez vous
c'est en accès libre et on peut se voir
en une fois plusieurs fois suivant les
besoins du jeune mercy stéphanie gareau
je rappelle que vous êtes en charge du
pôle jeunesse de montigny le bretonneux
et donc cette soirée des métiers et de
l'orientation elle est au programme
demain mercredi au pôle jeunesse
justement c'est de 17h30 à 20h30 au 3par
dit des sources
cette action solidaire à présent des
pompiers en faveur de l'australie qui a
ravagé par les incendies dix personnes
dont huit sapeurs pompiers des yvelines
vont aller sur place afin de prêter main
forte aux secours ils partent du 6 au 21
février
leur mission est d' aux animaux dont
plus d'un milliard sont morts
reconstruction et accompagnement des
pompiers locaux une démarche
indépendante et financé en partie grâce
à une cagnotte en ligne les propos sont
recueillis par mélanie poker on sait
pertinemment qu depuis à plusieurs
semaines ils sont à bout ils commencent
à être fatigués et ont juste leur
apporter un soutien on n'a pas la
prétention de venir
révolutionner australie mais on veut
apporter notre petit soutien c'est nous
qui avons choisi de faire ça totalement
bénévolement on a posé des congés on a
financé noah billets d'avion et c'est
pour ça qu'on a créé une petite cagnotte
afin de nous aider dans les différents
frais sur place et notamment pourquoi
pas dans le financement de différents
matériels pour les gens peu désoeuvrés à
l'intervention des pompiers avaient été
justement nécessaires sur cet incident
rappelez vous le 12 juin 2018 le rer b
avait déraillé au niveau de saint rémy
les chevreuse faisant sept blessés
légers et le bureau d'enquêté accident
du transport terrestre vient de rendre
ses conclusions l accident a été
provoqué par l'érosion du remblai
soutenant les rails à un endommagement
provoquées par les pluies
exceptionnelles tombé à l'époque en
ile-de-france depuis le déraillement est
la ratp a la ratp est mise en place des
actions de surveillance des zones
sensibles du réseau ferroviaire 15
chroniqueurs et invités et 117 émissions
déjà diffusées sur les ondes de marmites
fmc la quatrième saison d'antisèches sur
le 88.4 le programme co produit avec
jolie preuve en est à sa quatrième
saison je le disais et en direct tous
les soirs à partir de 20 heures tous les
mercredis soir à partir de 20 heures le
sujet de maths il domine rassembler
autour de la table les chroniqueurs
d'antisèches prépare l'émission du soir
sur marmite fm avec quelques minutes de
la prise d'antenne les dernières
consignes sont données pour romain
nouveau dans l'émission ses relectures
de chronique je suis pas forcément
invité de la radio donc doit penser
radio je dois penser aussi public parce
que ça doit être accessible pour les
personnes forcément kuti qui écoutent
l'émission et qui sont pas forcément ni
des agrégés de philo hanigan signifié au
final c'est ce qu'ont fait aussi avec
nos chroniques on fait avec ce qu'on
aime on fait avec ce qu'on fait avec ce
qu'on est
il est 20 heures c'est l'heure de
l'antisèche sur marne itfm bonjour à
tous la sonnerie qui retentit on la
baisse un petit peu bienvenue sur
marmite fm le 88.4 vous êtes dans le
l'antisèche les missions que personne
en asie on trouve julien dénervaud à la
réalisation et l'animation à travers la
vitre son rôle est de créer une énergie
entre les chroniqueurs et les invités
pour avoir intox chaud avec du rire de
la bonne humeur et des informations
positives à transmettre à l'auditeur
dans l'anti sage tu peux découvrir plein
de trucs tu peux tu peux vraiment
découvrir des artistes locaux
ça c'est vraiment la prod l'objectif
numéro 1 tu peux aussi apprendre plus
sur des gens plus connus comme gérard
majax était venue dans l'émission ou
encore les vertes qu'on aura
la semaine prochaine
tu peux aussi à apprendre des trucs à
raconter à la bastide a été à fait au
programme de l'émission les questions de
marie les instruments insolites de kevin
ou encore la philo pop de romain clerc
passe à l'antenne depuis deux ans et
chaque mercredi c'est toujours le même
plaisir
ces munitions on se prend pas la tête où
on pose son cerveau pendant deux minutes
et juste on s'amuse et en fait on se
rend compte que même imposant son
cerveau donc en prendre plein de trucs
et c'est ça qui est super c'est la
quatrième saison pour antisèches qui
compte à son actif 117 émission de talk
show est à retrouver sur le 88.4 ou en
podcast sur le site de marmites fm il
est attendu chaque année par les chefs
cuisiniers du monde entier le guide
michelin a dévoilé ce lundi son palmarès
2020 pas de nouvelles étoiles pour les
yvelines mais bonne nouvelle les sept
restaurants une étoile conservent leur
distinction à savoir notamment les
établissements versailles et du gordon
ramsay de la table du 11 ou encore la
table des blu à dampierre et le numéro
trois au tremblay sur mauldre depuis le
15 janvier les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines célèbre le
compte un voyage à travers des
rencontres des conférences et des
animations le week-end dernier à la
médiathèque jean rousselot à guyancourt
partageaient les traditions antillaises
mélanie poquet et nicolas landry
[Musique]
des contes dansés et chantés aux rythmes
du gwoka à la médiathèque jean rousselot
des associations saint-quentinoise ont
fait découvrir les antilles tradition
danser et culinaires pour célébrer le
cou aux antilles on est beaucoup dans
l'oralité et
transmet beaucoup de générations en
générations à travers le conte et qui
dit content dit musique qui dit musique
dit instruments chez nous et tout cela
se mêlent se mélange il ya des comptes
où les ombres le côté on raconte
d'histoires dix danseurs l'histoire il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont offerts
musique
pour cette 19ème édition de la fête du
conte et médiathèques emmène les
lecteurs en voyage arrive trip qui a
fait étape à guyancourt pour une escale
dans les îles
on s'est dit qu'au mois de janvier
février un petit peu de soleil dans nos
médiathèque ça ferait pas de mal et donc
donc c'était relativement facile et puis
c'est vrai aussi
l'idée c'était aussi de travailler avec
des avec des associations du territoire
les médiathèques vous conte des
histoires jusqu'au samedi 1er février
[Musique]
pour refermer ce journal la page dédiée
aux élections municipales premier tour
au programme le 15 mars prochain
direction guyancourt d'abord pour
connaître les enjeux de la commune
réaménagement du quartier construction
sur l'ancienne friche thales ligne 18
entreprises ont fait le point avec
michael et demi d'euros l'un des
principaux enjeux a dû en cours sera
l'ancienne friche thales comment ce
secteur va être réaménagé cette zone
implanté entre l'avenue léon blum et
celle de l'europe devrait accueillir
d'ici 2030 plus de 1300 logements des
commerces des activités économiques des
espaces verts des services publics sur
plus de 22 hectares le site qui sera
baptisé le quartier des savoirs va
également accueillir la future station
de métro saint quentin est du grand
paris express un super métro reliant
orly a versé en 30 minutes
avec ce nouveau quartier le nombre de
gurs courtois devrait passer de 29 mille
à trente deux mille habitants
les logements justement seront un
deuxième enjeu a eu recours la ville
compte actuellement près de 48 % de
logements sociaux 18% de plus que la
moyenne des communes voisines
faut-il aller plus loin ou réduire ce
chiffre d'autre part la ville a entamé
depuis quelques années une
reconfiguration de ses quartiers
notamment des transformations dans le
quartier du pont du rotois depuis 2006
l'un des plus vieux quartiers de la
ville créée en 1974
enfin les entreprises seront également
un enjeu la ville compte à ce jour 2536
firme sur son territoire presque 1000 de
plus qu'en 2012 parmi elles des grosses
entreprises comme sodexo le groupe à ce
mode est spécialisé dans les jeux de
société ou encore le technocentre
renault qui emploie près de 9500
personnes la ville doit-elle accueillir
plus entreprises à magny les hameaux le
maire sortant sera bien candidat
bertrand guillon bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes à la tête de la ville depuis 2012
suite à la démission de jacquelot lloze
vous serez en lice pour un troisième
mandat lors de ces municipales tête de
liste du collectif ensemble pour magny
les hameaux c'était une évidence pour
vous de vous présenter à nouveau pour ce
scrutin évidence une continuité on va
dire puisque le travail qui a été
effectué et collectivement à manille
avec l'équipe municipale a permis
d'avancer dans des transformations de la
ville dans une continuité de service
public dans une mobilisation des
habitants et on propose tout simplement
aux habitants pouvoir continuer tout ça
donc poursuivre des projets quel bilan
vous faites sur ce dernier mandat
s'était finalement votre premier mandat
complet à la tête de magny les hameaux
alors ce mandat était complexe d'un côté
puisque on est face à un assèchement des
finances locales
et puis à des changements de périmètre
de l'agglomération de compétences aussi
ou de partage de compétences entre les
communes et l'agglomération
donc il a fallu faire avec tout ça se
battre aussi pour une continuité des
services publics de proximité se
mobiliser pour pouvoir permettre aux
habitants d'accéder toujours à leurs
services mais aussi de pouvoir
transformer la commune en terme de
transition écologique en termes de
participation citoyenne en termes de
renforcement du lien social
donc tout ça on l'a menée
avec à la fois un certain nombre
d'actions fait avec les habitants et
puis beaucoup de mobilisations vis-à-vis
de l'ensemble des partenaires de la
commune on a parlé de ces thématiques
dans un instant puisqu'elles font partie
de vos priorités aussi pour le prochain
mandat sur lequel vous êtes candidat
vous êtes bien sûr un homme de gauche
bertrand ou lyon aujourd'hui sous la
bannière à deux générations le mouvement
de benoît hamon votre liste et pourtant
revendiqué sans étiquette
pourquoi ce choix finalement les
étiquettes importe peu alice elle à
l'échelle d'une commune c'est
l'important ce n'est pas l'étiquette
c'est les valeurs qu'on défend on met
trop les jambes bandées dans des boxes
dans des cases et moi je ne défends pas
un parti je ne dépends pas non plus d'un
parti chacun doit garder sa liberté par
contre il est essentiel que nous soyons
attachés à des valeurs fortes
des valeurs qui permettent le progrès
social des valeurs qui permettent la
solidarité des valeurs qui permettent de
vivre en harmonie avec notre
environnement
des valeurs qui permettent de faire
confiance aux citoyens et de les
associer de kof élaboré avec l'ensemble
des habitants avec tout simplement nos
voisines à nos voisins
et forcément à partir de là avec ces
valeurs là je ne vais pas demander à des
gens qui veulent s'investir qui
s'investissent déjà pour beaucoup sur la
commune dans quelle partie son etc
à partir du moment où ces valeurs nous
réunissent nous avons signé
ensemble une charte de l'engagement qui
est public d'ailleurs qui est sur le
site d'ensemble pour manille sur
laquelle on retrouve l'ensemble des
valeurs et puis la méthode qui nous unit
et puis bah du coup à l'intérieur de la
liste et puis de l'équipe beaucoup plus
large tu es qui est notre notre
collectif bien nous avons des gens qui
adhèrent peut-être dans les partis
d'autres pas du tout des gens qui sont
en tout cas très actif au niveau de la
commune et qui ont à coeur de pouvoir
s'investir pour les autres ni votre
équipe samx aussi bien des élus actuels
comme des nouveaux visages
il ya un renouvellement forcément et
donc on a des élus qui vont continuer
sur en tout cas qui souhaitent continuer
sur sur le prochain mandat
et puis des personnalités nouvelles on a
ce renouvellement classique
alors depuis le début de l'année vous
organiser des ateliers citoyens ça c'est
pour préparer votre programme pour le
prochain mandat
alors on a d'abord commencé par ce qu'on
a appelé des cafés citoyens
on l'avait déjà organisé pendant le
mandat l'objectif étant de pouvoir
partager le bilan avec les habitants de
pouvoir discuter du bilan et depuis de
pouvoir aussi entrevoir avec eux les
éléments clés ou les choses à améliorer
affaires à faire progresser ou arrêter
tout simplement
donc ça ça nous a permis de finaliser
notre bilan en décembre et en janvier on
est passé cette fois sur le projet et
donc on a mis en place des ateliers
citoyens pour pouvoir travailler donc
par différents groupes sur les
thématiques pour pouvoir créer le projet
municipal pour les années à venir
alors justement la participation des
citoyens c'est l'un des quatre grands
thèmes que vous défendez ça veut dire
quoi associer davantage les citoyens à
la décision communale ça veut dire c'est
l'idée ça veut dire qu élaboré avec les
avec les habitants on a déjà engagé un
certain nombre de choses pendant le
mandat on va continuer de développer ces
choses là ça a été de mettre en place
des ateliers sur les différents projets
de la commune
des ateliers où les habitants
volontaires bon on définit tout
simplement le projet le cahier des
charges et se sont investis pour la
transformation de leur commune c'est
aussi sur la gestion urbaine de
proximité des réunions régulières avec
les habitants pour qu'ils puissent nous
relayer des informations sur la vie
quotidienne dans leur quartier
tout simplement autour de chez eux pour
pouvoir faire des réaménagements pour
pouvoir régler des difficultés de la vie
quotidienne qu'ils peuvent avoir
et puis c'est aussi faire participer les
gens directement comme dans le conseil
de gestion par exemple du centre social
qui est le lieu des initiatives des
habitants quelqu'un qui veut créer un
atelier qui veut créer une activité pour
pour les autres vous faire une sortie
pour pouvoir emmener ses voisins peut le
faire dans le cadre de son social tout
ça l'objectif c'est de l'amplifier et
surtout de le rendre finalement
totalement officiel que ce mode de
fonctionnement à magny les hameaux
souhaite une norme
parlant de la transition écologique est
l'une des autres priorités on rappelle
que la commune est membre du parc
naturel régional de la haute vallée de
chevreuse pendant votre mandat des
bâtiments ont été réhabilités des
bâtiments énergivores
vous souhaitez également voir apparaître
sur les toits de magny les hameaux des
panneaux photovoltaïques donc s'engager
davantage dans les énergies
renouvelables
là encore on a engagé la démarche
pendant ce mandat une démarche forte
vis-à-vis de la biodiversité vis-à-vis
des mobilités et vis-à-vis de la
rénovation énergétique et un fort enjeu
dans l'ensemble de notre territoire sur
la rénovation énergétique on a travaillé
avec l'agencé locale de l'énergie du
climat et on a choisi durant le mandat
les trois plus le bâtiment les plus
énergivores
le dernier les travaux vont commencer
cette année c'est le bâtiment du gymnase
auguste delaune
et bien entendu on va continuer cette
démarche et à côté de ça nous avons
travaillé par rapport à des énergies
renouvelables on a aujourd'hui par
exemple notre sens technique municipal
qui est alimenté par une chaudière bois
et avec le parc naturel régional nous
réfléchissons par rapport à l'énergie
photovoltaïque d énergie solaire
rennes qui avec seulement des toits pour
accueillir opérative c'est en moyenne
donc qui est à l'initiative ou
accompagné par par le parc naturel
certain nombre de réunions ont eu lieu
directement à manier on leur prête les
locaux pour pouvoir organiser tout ça et
nous avons décidé de pouvoir leur mettre
à disposition des toitures de bâtiments
publics et aujourd'hui donc les études
vont avoir lieu par ce collectif pour
pouvoir voir les positionnements des
toits voir aussi les longueurs de fils à
tirer si si nécessaire et puis
finalement finaliser la faisabilité de
ces éléments là l'objectif encore et au
delà de rendre les bâtiments moins
énergivores de pouvoir aussi avoir des
alternatives en termes d'énergie un mix
énergétique
dernière chose c'est aussi la transition
écologique peut-être réduire le problème
de la circulation sur la commune
vous souhaitez notamment relier le
réseau cyclable existante saint quentin
en yvelines au reste de magny les
hameaux aussi avoir davantage de bus sur
la koala sur le réseau cyclable on a
déjà progressé d'accord pendant ce
mandat pas encore totalement il ya
encore des des cheminements à régler
nous aurons du travail aussi en terme de
stationnement plus sécurisé de
déploiement aussi des offres de location
de vélos et puis en termes de bus on a
également progressé avec des bus express
qui se sont développés et qui nous
emmène vers les gares de versailles
chantiers ou de saint quentin en
yvelines il faut qu'on puisse encore
progressé en termes d'offre de bus
notamment le week-end et notamment le
dimanche
donc c'est des demandes que nous
continuons et que nous continuerons de
reléguer vers l'agglomération
et puis il ne faut rien s'interdire en
termes de mobilité depuis longtemps je
demande maintenant une étude qui puisse
nous permettent de voir la faisabilité
d'un transport par câble entre magny les
hameaux et guyancourt et éventuellement
aussi depuis sa réalité chevreuse pour
relier pour relier donc la future gare
de l'es18
c'est un élément qui peut être
intéressant mais qu'il faut étudier tout
simplement parce qu on agrandira pas les
routes on fera pas de viaduc routier
on ne fera pas tunnel routier et il faut
qu'on passe les vallées deux autres de
vos priorités c'est lien social et la
solidarité que l'on aura bien sûr le
temps de développer au cours de cette
campagne je précise aussi qu on retrouve
vos rendez vous de campagne comme ceux
des autres candidats de magny les
hameaux sur le site internet de tv 78
merci bertrand oignons persil maire
sortant de magny les hameaux tête de
liste ensemble pour mamie est les
hameaux face à vous pour le scrutin
le conseil municipal d'opposition lionel
lindemann avec la liste manie citoyens
et peut-être une autre candidature
la liste reste à boucler celle de
dominique grattepain qui est ancien
conseiller municipal de la commune
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
d'avoir suivi belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]